and here welcome to the studio a long
Grand chess tour what do you feel about
your results uh well I did quite well in
the
um classic part but of course I I didn't
do so well in the rabbit and Blitz so
that's something to to work on I guess
because I felt that in the classical
tournaments I was having my chances and
even in this Tournament of course I I
feel that I should have done better
because I just didn't convert three
clearly winning positions so in general
I was I was feeling quite okay in the
classical but yeah not so much in the in
the rabbit and Blitz unfortunately I
have to say after your game against Fabi
where you were losing but managed to
save it it felt that the theme of the
tournament was Lanier almost won yes
what was missing for you to get those
full points yeah I don't know I guess I
was lagging a bit of energy especially
because I was playing long games most of
the time and uh just yeah at the end I
mean
it was a bit unfortunate because I mean
it in some of the games it like
yesterday for example it seemed that I
was doing everything
um
everything okay but then at the end I
was just missing the last uh just the
last uh part and uh but I think yeah the
lack of probably lack of energy uh was
was uh was crucial
um in my games I know that yesterday
Peters Fiddler saw you in the street and
he couldn't help himself but to ask
what you chose in this particular
position a random move I I yeah I play
King H3 without realizing that King King
H4 loses I don't know what what I was
thinking but yeah it's I mean
uh it would have been really painful to
to lose that way so I guess I mean I was
actually happy when Peter told me that
at least something that I can be happy
about it like a little positivity from
the game right yeah it was a crazy Queen
end game but it definitely felt that you
had it in the bag right how do you
recover from these positions where
you're not winning you're not winning
they must take a toll on you yeah I mean
it's it's uh it's really uh unpleasant
list for me I mean it's sometimes it
it's even more unpleasant than to lose a
game uh just to spoil some completely
winning position because you the the the
feeling of me's chances is really
annoying and it's it's stays there for
for some time but on the other hand I of
course uh
try to to look at the next game to look
at the future I mean
I came to realize at some point that you
don't have to be so dramatic in in chess
or you know it's it's just of course you
will miss chances you will miss huge
chances and sometimes you will get lucky
so it's better to try to be a little bit
pragmatic so that's what I think of it's
still kind of annoying but I mean that's
that's at least what I what I try to do
and
just just try to to keep going spoken
from a lot of experience linear you are
the leading player to come from Latin
America speaking of the future tell us
what's in store for you yeah well uh I
still have some some
um exciting tournaments this year first
of all the the 960 which is always fun
uh then uh the U.S championship of
course it's it's a big event I'll try to
to to be ready for that and then also
some online
tournaments as well so uh
um still some tests to to replay well I
know you've always dazzled us with your
theory we certainly look forward to
seeing more of your games here in the
960 and of course in the US
championships coming up starting on
October 5th thank you for joining us
here in the studio and on your results
here especially in the classical side of
the grand chess tour thank you indeed
thank you Lanier just missing the Final
Touch